80 جثمانا فلسطينيا قد وصلت الى معبر كرم
سالم وسلمت الى وزاره الصحه في رفح طبعا
الجيش الاسرائيلي قام بنبش قبور
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه خلال العمليه
البريه وقام باحتجاز هذه الجثامين في
الداخل الفلسطيني المحتل لا يعرف ماذا فعل
فيها بالضبط ولكن ما وصل الى منطقه رفح يا
الاعداد يعني لم تصل كل الجثامين بمعنى ان
هناك جثامين لازالت محتجزه في الداخل
الفلسطيني المحتل بقرار اسرائيلي الجثامين
التي تصل الى هنا الثمين قد اصاب شيء من
التحلل وقد اصابها يعني تشوهات بفعل يعني
عدم الدفن وهناك صعوبه في التعرف على هذه
الجثامين هناك صعوبه التعرف على
هويات هذه الين التي وصلت من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عبر معبض ط او سالم اكثر من 80
جثمانا مجهول الويا دون معلومات دون تقديم
اي معلومات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يسلم
الجثامين د وهي مشوهه غير معروفه التفاصيل
ودون معلومات حول ماهيه الاستشهاد ماهيه
ال يعني اين نبشت من اين حصلوا عليها اين
وجودت لا معلومات ابدا عن هذه ال وهي الان
تدفن وهناك شهود كبيره وزاره الصحه النيه
للتعرف
عليها